in u.s. foreign policy then Monday at
noon
Patricia O'Toole author of when trumpets
call Theodore Roosevelt after the White
House she was interviewed on afterwards
by former Senate Majority Leader Tom
Daschle President Bush's holiday reading
this weekend on book TV Princeton
philosophy professor Harry Frankfurt is
authored the best-selling exegesis on
the [ __ ] he spoke about it at Miami
Book Fair international for 45 minutes
all right calm down we've got a full day
ahead of us we let's not take it up
reporting thank you all for coming I'm
excited to be here you know we could go
Barbara called me and asked me if I'd
like to introduce an author at the book
fair and naturally I said I would be
honored to and then she said well we
have the perfect book for you
now I know now when she told me that I
would be introducing mr. Frankfurt of
the book on [ __ ] you know it's a
little disconcerting because you wonder
is there something about me that reeks
[ __ ] is there something that somehow
I've done something I've written I like
to think that maybe it's perhaps that I
would point out [ __ ] but that could
be [ __ ] in itself but then I realize
that I would get to say the word
[ __ ] on c-span and that alone made
it worthwhile so I'm very happy because
I was I was talking to Professor
Frankfurt just a few minutes ago and I
was telling him I think probably every
community believes this that they have
that their politicians their local
officials there they're a chattering
class has a particular hold on [ __ ]
but I kind of think I'd like to think
proudly think that Miami also has has
its own sort of unique sort of place in
in the world when it comes to that that
that sort of arrogance and and a mixture
of I guess arrogance and laziness that
sort of lets you one sort of promote
ideas without actually thinking them
through and since and as a journalist I
can certainly attest to that and as
someone who tries to avoid it I realized
after reading this book that I need to
be a little bit careful sometimes
because you know it's easy to slip into
[ __ ] but we'll hear more from that
from Professor Frankfurt so let me just
do the introduction very very quickly
and move on you know professor frankfurt
harry frankfurt is is considered one of
the most influential moral philosophers
in this country he has written several
books most recently the reasons of love
and the importance of what I care about
and then of course on [ __ ] he is a
professor emeritus of philosophy at
Princeton University and he first wrote
this book 20 years ago but I let him
talk to you more about that professor
frankfurt are you are you going to be
around come on out there everyone I
would like to just sort of thank you
very much and let's enjoy the
let's give a big hand of applause for a
professor Harry frankly
my book was published early this year
about 10 or 11 months ago and in the
period since then I received quite a
large number of emails and other
communications from people who had seen
it and wanted to tell me what they
thought some of the emails some of the
communications were very very pleasant
for me to receive they were from people
who told me how much they enjoyed the
book how valuable they thought it was
what a perceptive and illuminating
discussion I had provided those were the
best then there was another category of
emails from people who offered
suggestions about how I might improve
what I had done
information that I had overlooked that
they thought might be helpful and
sometimes it was very helpful a lot of
it I thought came from people who were
cranks but some of it some of it was
quite quite useful and illuminating then
there was a third category of emails
which at first I didn't take very
seriously but it turned out that there
were so many of them in this category
that I had to take it seriously I had to
take them seriously the the point of
these emails was that my book itself was
an instance of what I was trying to
explain not only not only was my book
nothing but an instance of [ __ ] but
that I knew that it was and I had
intended it to be such that I had
written it with my tongue in my cheek
and that I had tried to put something
over on people or at least to give them
a laugh well I don't want to say whether
I don't want to talk about whether my
book may itself be an instance of
[ __ ] I'll leave that for others to
judge but I can tell you with absolute
confidence that the other part of the
claim namely that I knew that it was and
that I intended to be such I can tell
you with absolute confidence that that
was entirely false
I wrote the essay as Jim said about 20
years ago around 1985 when I was
teaching at Yale University
and at that time I was a member of a
small group of faculty from various
departments which meant more or less
regularly to discuss ideas and to talk
about each other's work and generally to
to get in touch with each other's minds
and the kind of work we were doing and
part of the arrangement was that every
member of the group had at some point to
present a piece of his own work for
discussion and it was for that purpose
that I wrote the essay that doesn't
explain why I wrote it about [ __ ]
I had to write something but not
necessarily about that now what I can
tell you about that is this I was
trained as an analytic philosopher that
is to say as somebody whose major
concerns and skills were in dissecting
concepts which were commonly used but
which were generally not very well
understood and it occurred to me that
[ __ ] was in my case such a concept
that I had been using this term fairly
freely for a long time as a kind of a
dismissive insult against people or
against things that I had heard or read
but that I didn't really know what I
meant by it so I decided to try to find
out what the term did mean what it meant
at least in as I understood it and to
clarify to define to explain to make
entirely explicit and clear what the
concept of [ __ ] actually amounted to
shortly after I presented the well let
me tell you about the presentation I
presented this essay to the group and
they received it fairly soberly as an
academic group might be expected to do
they were appreciative I don't remember
much about the actual discussion but I
do remember one comment that was made by
one of the members of the group he's
actually a physicist who said that he
thought it was especially appropriate
that the essay had been written at Yale
because after all Yale is he said the
[ __ ] capital of the world what he
had in mind was that that that at that
time Jacques Derrida and Paul de man
were members of the faculty and so were
other leading figures of the
postmodernist group of literary
criticism I don't know if Yale could
compete successfully with Miami as a
world center for [ __ ] but at any
rate that's how it scene seemed to some
soon after I presented it the essay was
published in a small Journal published
at Rutgers University called rare attack
a literary and intellectual journal and
then Minh also appeared somewhat
mysteriously or at least anonymously on
the internet I didn't put it on the
internet I didn't even know that was
going on the internet but several people
who knows how things get on the internet
it's a great mystery to me at least
several people put it on the internet at
various sites so it was available quite
widely and I began to get responses to
that I got I remember two particularly
odd requests that came to me one was
from a young man who was a student at a
music conservatory in Wales and he had
been given the assignment of putting
some prose to music and he wanted my
permission to put some of my essay to
music so I said sure go ahead and do it
and in due course I got a CD with his
music which I must confess was not
terribly not terribly appealing the
other requests came that I remember came
from a commodities trader in Chicago the
Chicago Board of Trade who told me that
he was interested in establishing a
prize an annual prize for the commodity
investment newsletter which had the
greatest proportion of [ __ ] in its
decks he wanted to call it the Harry
Frankfurt prize and he wanted my
permission to use my name in this way
well I gave him permission but nothing
really came of it in the end he wrote to
me and said that he had been unable to
get the authority of the Board of
Directors some board of directors to
which to whose authority he was subject
they wouldn't go along with it so he had
to drop the idea he didn't say why they
wouldn't go along with it but I suppose
that they were they were reluctant to to
encourage competition in the production
of [ __ ] they probably figured there
was already enough and that they didn't
have to order a proffer a prize to
encourage people to produce more in any
case a couple of years ago maybe a year
and a half or two years ago I started
editing a series of philosophy books for
the Princeton University Press called
Princeton monographs and philosophy and
the editor at the press with whom I
worked was a man named Ian Malcolm and
one day when I was talking to him he
said you know I've been thinking about
your essay on [ __ ] which seems to
have a track
quite an enthusiastic following though
it's only on the internet and in this
rather obscure journal why don't we
bring it out is it a little book I said
how can it be a book it's only about 25
pages long
he said well we can do a lot with
margins and typefaces and page sizes and
and that's what they did they brought
out this little book it's not even 70
pages long but it's in a hardcover like
a proper book is supposed to be and it
seems to have done fairly well I'm not
going to assume of course that everybody
here or even that anybody here has
actually read the book so I'll tell you
a little bit about what's in it and a
little bit about what's not in it the
the the primary purpose of the book was
to try to explain to try to explicate to
illuminate the concept of [ __ ] and
provide what struck me as necessary and
sufficient conditions for the correct
application of that concept so what I
what I came up with was that the the the
essence of [ __ ] is that the person
who produces it doesn't really care
whether what he's saying is true or
false
he's not engaged in the enterprise of
conveying information or in deceiving
people he's engaged in the enterprise of
manipulating opinions manipulating
attitudes and and feelings and he will
say whatever he thinks will be effective
in that respect regardless of whether
it's true or false he's not interested
in in telling the truth nor is he
interested in in in lying or in
conveying falsehood the whole question
of whether something is true and fall
true or false is a matter of total
indifference to him we live in a
marketing society we live in a society
when we're in which everybody is trying
to sell something trying to sell a
product or a person or a policy or a
program and in the in the enterprise of
trying to sell things one is trying to
get people to buy them and that means
manipulating or at least affecting their
beliefs affecting their attitudes
affecting their feelings affecting the
way in which they respond to whatever it
is that you are trying to sell there's
so much of this that it has become
normal we tend to tolerate it without
much without much resistance so
or resentment if somebody tells a lie we
feel violated we feel that some kind of
real offense has been committed when we
encounter somebody who is producing
[ __ ] we we may be irritated we may
turn away with an irritated shrug but we
don't feel that there's some kind of
punishment is in order if if a political
figure if someone in high public office
is caught lying or is caught telling
what seems to people to be alive is a
tremendous commotion there are irate
letters to the editor there are angry
editorials in the papers there are
inquiries by the Senate or by the house
all sorts of things go on there may even
be a grand jury convened that leads to
an indictment if a politician is caught
bullshitting people say well what do you
expect it's sort of what that's the way
the game is played we don't take it
seriously in the same way as we take
lying although in my view and this is
one of the points I tried to make in the
book [ __ ] is a more insidious threat
to our culture to our civilization than
lying is because [ __ ] encourages and
and normalizes if that's a word makes
people accept as normal
indifference to the truth it undermines
our general feeling that truth is
important and that it warrants respect
and concern the liar is not like that
the liar actually is concerned about the
truth he can't tell a lie unless he
believes he knows what's true and there
is nothing in the activity of lying that
encourages people to stop taking truth
seriously on the contrary we take it
very seriously as is indicated by the
fact that we respond so vehemently when
we discover or feel we've discovered
that a lie has been told whereas we
don't respond with the same intensity of
feeling the same sense of being injured
or offended when we encounter somebody
who is giving us giving us [ __ ] I
said that one of the reasons why there
is so much [ __ ] Pera perhaps the
basic reasons because we live in a
marketing society we also live in a
society in which there's an enormous
amount of talk
there are professional talkers on talk
shows on shows with talking heads on on
programs on the radio and on TV as well
as in in the print media and in
Hollywood in which people are paid to
talk so they go on talking and they go
on talking beyond the point at which
they know what they're talking about and
the result of that is inevitably and
inescapably that they produce they begin
producing [ __ ] and they can't stop
talking because they stop talking they
don't get paid so this is another
feature of our culture that is
responsible for the the the prevalence
and the persistence of [ __ ] there's
another consideration which I mentioned
in the book I'm a little uneasy about it
because it may have implications that
are disturbing but part of the reason
why there's so much [ __ ] is because
we as we suppose at least many of us do
that it's the duty of a citizen of a
good citizen to have opinions about
everything
he can't have an opinion about
everything that's well informed you
can't have an opinion to everything
that's based on a careful analysis of
the relevant data the result is if you
feel you have to have an opinion about
everything that you're gonna have lots
of opinions that are nothing more than
[ __ ] I wish I could say something
useful or interesting at least about how
to how to deal with this issue
I think [ __ ] is a very serious
problem it undermines our respect for
the truth and I think that that's that's
something to be worried about I don't
know how to cope with it that I say I
don't know what we could do to diminish
the amount of [ __ ] in our culture or
to rid ourselves of it education
obviously doesn't work
everybody's educated these days we send
an enormous number of people to college
they come out just as gullible and ready
to accept [ __ ] passively as they
were when they went in I'd be interested
in knowing what some of you may think
about how we can cope with this we could
laugh at it try to humiliate people who
produce [ __ ] by laughing at them by
making it clear that we see through them
and that we don't take them seriously
the trouble is that laughter doesn't
really get heard
doesn't really doesn't really reach its
target in an effective vigorous way we
can complain of course and we could vote
out those politicians who we feel
indulge in this to to greater an extent
the trouble is we might end up with all
or many public officers remaining empty
we don't want the country run by people
who don't believe in the importance of
truth but I'm not sure that we're ready
for not running the country at all so
that's one of the problems that I left
on solved or even undealt with in the
book another is what accounts in
addition to the few meager comments that
I that I offered what accounts for the
prevalence and persistence of [ __ ]
in our culture you have to believe or
you laugh I think it's it's reasonable
to suppose that's something that is so
prevalent and so persistent must be
serving some useful purpose otherwise
why would it last why would we continue
to accept it why does society so passive
and so permissive with respect to it
unless unless it believes unless it
feels at some level that it's worth
something that it's doing some some kind
of serving some kind of useful purpose
and I'd like to know what people think
about what useful purpose it may
possibly be construed as serving well I
think I will give up the microphone at
this point and invite you to tell me
what you think about some of these
issues
thank you as OnPoint as possible and
avoid the [ __ ] I noticed that you
use the masculine pronoun throughout and
I'm going to make a basic assumption and
ask you how much more prone you think
men are to [ __ ] than women I don't
have any I don't have any solid data on
this issue what occurs to me is that
when men and women come together as in
romantic relationships
I'm just asking myself who is likely to
produce the most [ __ ] in that
situation I I think that it's a it's
it's a tie it seems to be here perhaps
you could think politics government oh
sure that's the greatest source that's
the most prolific source of [ __ ]
most reliable source I think all
politicians are bullshitters I don't
know of any real exceptions to that and
it's it's it's natural they're trying to
sell themselves they're trying to sell
their policies and programs and they
were there they're in the business of
manipulating opinion I don't think it
necessarily follows from anything I've
said that the democratic societies are
more likely to include a lot of [ __ ]
than others because governments even in
undemocratic societies depend upon the
acquiescence if not the support of the
public in order to remain in office they
can't remain they can't they can't
retain their power if everybody's
against them so they have to they have
to win over the public to some extent at
least to to the extent of encouraging
the public orders require leading the
public to remain passive and quiescent
so I think even in a totalitarian
society you're going to get an enormous
amount of [ __ ] what more can I say
thank you you're welcome a few things
one do we tend to do it tolerate it
because we
and to do it ourselves what about gossip
and when we [ __ ] to one another
outside and obviously commercial context
what are we trying to sell well as for
whether we tolerate it because we are
aware that we do it ourselves you have
to speak for yourself I at least never
engaged as for the other aspect of your
comment or question could you repeat it
when in normal everyday discourse yeah
what are people trying to sell to one
another and what are they afraid I mean
in other words it's very rare to find
somebody you've made her your professor
who speaks tries to speak the truth and
he analyzes these things well I think
people are trying to sell themselves
they're trying to present themselves as
being individuals of a certain kind of
having virtuous characteristics or
admirable characteristics or enviable
characteristics and in this enterprise
they are trying to manipulate and to
manage the opinions and attitudes of
others towards them so what they are
trying to sell as I say is themselves
and for this purpose they will use
whatever they think will be effective in
achieving it the last thing was gossip
thanks a gossip yeah
I'm just trying I'm trying to ask myself
whether gossip is an especially fertile
ground for [ __ ] I don't know whether
it is I suppose gossip that has a that
has a that has an aim when I gossipy in
order to create certain impression of
the person about whom I'm retailing this
gossip that that may very well entail
the production of [ __ ] but if I'm
simply reporting the fact if I'm simply
telling you that so-and-so is likely to
get engaged to so-and-so or that
so-and-so is probably stealing from
these partners that may be an attempt on
my part to convey information and and
not entail any any element of [ __ ]
so strictly speaking I don't know what
the connection between [ __ ] and
gossip may be I don't think it's a very
close connection how do you
differentiate between sigh excuse me how
do you differentiate between lying and
bull how it's the individuals able to do
that
well as I tried to understand it the
liar believes that he knows the truth
and chooses for reasons of his own to
say something that he knows is not true
that he believes it's not true so
there's a deliberate effort there to
conceal the truth and to replace it with
something that is not true the
bullshitter is indifferent to this
distinction he doesn't care whether what
he's saying is true or false he may not
even have an opinion about whether it's
true or false
he has an opinion only about whether
it'll be effective in achieving his
purpose in manipulating the opinions and
attitudes of the person to whom he's
addressing himself
well that's but that doesn't help one
how to differentiate between know how to
tell that one who is lying or just
should involve yes what you mean I guess
what you're asking how do we how do we
spot how do we identify the liar how do
we identify the liar and differentiated
from the bullshitter yes well that's a
good question and I don't know that
there is a general general rule that we
can use to help us to differentiate the
two some things we hear are
[ __ ] on the face of them because
it's clear at least it seems clear to us
that nobody could say such things who
really believe them who nobody could
believe such things there was a senator
who explained that in his view global
warming was the greatest hoax ever
perpetrated on the American people now
that to me seems clear to be a case of
which he couldn't possibly believe that
but I don't know if he was lying I think
he was just trying to try to make a
point trying to get us to accept a
certain policy or to reject a certain
policy he wasn't trying to explain the
facts to us or to help us to understand
the way the world is most people I think
believe of themselves that they're
pretty good at spotting [ __ ] when
it's offered to them and that may be one
of the reasons why people are not so
offended by it because they don't feel
that it's such a threat because they
feel that they can handle it and they
don't feel threatened by it in the same
way they feel threatened by lies which
are much more difficult to spot because
in order to tell that something's a lie
you have to know what the truth is and
you also have to have some reason to
believe that the person who's telling
you the line knows what the truth is and
that may be very difficult to
information to acquire lies are much
more sinister they're much more
difficult I think to identify than
[ __ ] which may cast doubt on my
claim that [ __ ] is a greater threat
to the culture than lying is but I do
think that it is because of this what I
said that the liar at least take
seriously the difference between truth
and falsity thinks it's an important
difference and he strives for that
reason to to conceal the truth or to
replace it whereas the [ __ ] of just
have to give a damn he doesn't think
that the whole question of whether
things are true or false makes much
difference at all he's not engaged in
that enterprise but I wish I could give
you a litmus test or some sort of
device for identifying or separating
lives from [ __ ] but I suppose it's
it's just something we learn in time
with common sense and experience some
people come across as bullshitters and
others come across as liars but I don't
know how I don't know exactly how to
explain that
what is the derivation of the word
that's another good question I looked it
up in the Oxford English Dictionary and
they have a lot of interesting data
there uses of it in literature and in
other contexts but there was no
indication of where the word comes from
one of the emails I received after my
book was published was from somebody who
claimed to know the origin of the word
[ __ ] I can tell you what he told me I
don't believe it but pass it on he he
said he said that in the 19th century
there was a practice of shipping manure
from one place to another because
they're very valuable as a fertilizer
and so places that needed fertilizers
ordered shipments of manure and the
practice was to store the manure in the
holes of chefs way down in the bottom of
the ship the manure emanated methane gas
which at the slightest encouragement
would blow up and the ship would suffer
and the owners of the ship would suffer
so the practice was developed of storing
the manure not in the holes not in the
bottom of the ship but but on top and
cases or bundles or I don't know how
they packed it but bundles of manure
were labeled store high in transit
it's a take-it-or-leave-it that's the
what that pool
yeah I think so sounds like it ideally I
wanted to respond to your request to to
talk a little bit about thee how do we
combat [ __ ] yeah and I think I have
found with the raising of my children
there are now teenagers that I would
point out [ __ ] as much as possible
in subtle ways take those opportunities
and and I think they have grown to be
savvy and to discern [ __ ] the most
recent that I can think of that I just
told my children we were walked we were
driving down the very street where a
brochure on these new condominiums that
are being built here in Miami these
brochures show one male with three
females in every picture and and this
incredible situation here and of course
that is complete [ __ ] so I pointed
it out to them and I said look look at
this picture here look at the building
look at what they've removed in the
surroundings look at these three people
these four people the one guy with the
three girls driving down the expressway
not a not a hair was blowing in this
convertible they were driving down and
we were just driving that and that's how
I do it that's how I point out the
[ __ ]
as much as I can so that's are you sure
you're helping them to detect it or
helping them showing them how to do it
okay
well I'll find out as they evolve
good luck thank you well considering
that your book is so popular are there
any regrets that you didn't publish it
20 years ago and has the country changed
says the academic political and business
climate changed so in the last 20 years
that the book is very much more popular
today because of the changes in the
country yeah that's a good question I
wondered why the book is so popular when
it was first published I thought well it
might sell a few copies because the the
spectacle of an Ivy League professor
using such coarse language and
discussing such a low topic might be
titillating and ending and entertaining
so a few people right by it but it's
been much more successful than that I'm
embarrassed to talk about it but it you
know it's been on the bestseller list
for 27 weeks and it sold several hundred
thousand copies and I wonder why it
can't be just this transgressive quality
that people are sort of aroused by this
spectacle that I that I described a few
moments ago I think people in this
country are starved for the truth I
think we're sick of the [ __ ] that
we're handed all the time that we feel
that we're being flooded with
and people have the idea whether it's
reasonable or not that my book might
help them to understand what's going on
and help them to cope with it in some
way as for the difference between 20
years ago and now I think that there is
more [ __ ] now I haven't any
real measure of it I can't give you any
statistics or I can't quantify the the
changes just my subjective impression is
that it's more difficult to avoid now
than it was 20 years ago there's there
are fewer opportunities to hear
straightforward talk about serious
matters and to get real information that
it's untainted by my [ __ ] or spin or
other modes of deforming the truth than
it was then why that should be I don't
know
incidentally I've thought about I
mentioned spin a moment ago I I thought
at one time of writing an essay on spin
which is a relatively as essay it's a
relatively new phenomenon I don't know
if the relatively new phenomenon but the
term is relatively new it's only in the
last few years that you've heard people
talk about spin I didn't get very far
with my effort to understand it but one
thing that occurred to me that seemed to
me to be suggestive I don't know exactly
what to do with it but the difference
between a [ __ ] artist and a spin
doctor
an artist is creative ingenious
inventive and we admire artists and they
we feel that they're serving some
valuable purpose a doctor we also admire
and respect doctors and I also serve
some useful purpose but they're not
creative in the same way they're not
inventing things they're fixing things
they start out with something that's
happened and they try to fix it they try
to change it from a morbid or a
pathological condition to a healthy one
the [ __ ] artist is not doing that
he's just try he's just better at
producing producing [ __ ] than the
ordinary person is so that's all I can
say about the difference between spin
and [ __ ] as I wish I could say more
about the development or the the
extension of of [ __ ] in the culture
but I can't okay my question relates to
[ __ ] in television news and it seems
to me that beginning in the 50s
television news went from being
journalistic journalistic meaning that
it dealt with facts or someone made a
statement of something and then
questions of whether what supports the
statement or what doesn't it went from
being journalistic then to being
concerned with public opinion and so
it's become more and more sort of George
Stephanopoulos please come forward and
interpret this what selling job the
president will have on this and whether
the Democrats will have an effective
hard-hitting response to it and so forth
so that the whole perspective of the TV
news now is outside that we are somehow
outside of all of this looking on it and
that the public is something other than
ourselves and that the that the news
anchors national news anchors are
content to wallow in that rather than
delving into
particularly recently back to war on
terrorism whether it's a real war in the
same sense of a war with him scenery or
a war on cancer or smoking so I was
wondering whether you would agree with
that
you know whether if you do agree with
that whether you might have remedies for
that I do agree with it there's an
enormous difference I think even between
the best news programs nowadays and what
we used to get with Edward R Morrow and
Eric severide and people like that who
were very serious journalists so we're
really trying to understand and help
others to understand what was going on
in the world rather than trying to
promote some way of looking at things
yeah
and also you didn't mention this but I
suppose it's behind what you were saying
that News has become news programs have
become a form of entertainment rather
than a form of Education or informing
people and with the enormous importance
of ratings in television the more
entertaining the program is the pirates'
ratings tend to be and so there's a
tremendous motivation for altering news
programs so that they become
entertaining so people will watch them
and have fun as for what to do about
that that reminds me of something quite
remarkable that happened recently in
which something actually was done about
a rather egregious instance of [ __ ]
on television Jon Stewart went on
crossfire one day and he told those
people off he told them that they were
just hacks that they were letting the
country down that they were failing to
maintain the responsibility that they
had of keeping the level of public
discourse at a reasonable at a
reasonable stage and he sort of they
were astounded because they brought him
on think he would be funny and that they
would have an entertaining program and
instead he just laced into them and the
remarkable thing beyond that was the
network cancelled the program he Jon
Stewart drove them off the air
that was that was really quite
extraordinary no I don't know how we
could reproduce that to drive other
programs of similar similar nefarious
character off the air but perhaps we
ought to analyze that situation and
figure out just what it was that John
Stewart did how he accomplished what he
did and see if we can we can reproduce
it in other in other contexts could I
have a follow-up sure actually I think
it's worth applause I don't think that
public radio is immune to this [ __ ]
either and you have the same Talking
Heads maybe they have lungs attached to
them yeah with this indirect Orwellian
type of dialogue I mean like in the
sense of politics and English language
that you know the circum lusion in this
decision-making environment what would
one perhaps going to expect anything
better from the leader that sort of
thing would you agree with that I do
agree with it it's an instance I think
of what I was talking about earlier when
I said that you get you get people who
are paid to talk and they have to keep
on talking whether they know what
they're talking about or not and so you
get a lot of [ __ ] and they are
encouraged to do this of course because
they make their living this way these
programs with Talking Heads and
ostensibly serious discussions of
serious public issues are largely
worthless so far as their value of
educating people and informing them and
conveying information that would really
help people to make reasonable decisions
about matters of public concern thank
you you're welcome
I wonder how you feel about the
transiency of American culture being
part of the promotion of this particular
characteristic in other words you can be
released from prison in California and
moved to Palm Beach and be a wholly
different person and and develop your
personality as you wish or you can move
from Palm Beach across the state to
Tampa and become a completely different
person how much do you feel that the
transient of our society contributes to
to the
particular characteristic that's an
interesting point the-the-the the
opportunities that this country offers
for people to make their own way and to
define their own careers and to define
their own characters is quite quite
exceptional and I suppose that it does
encourage people to believe in the
possibility of of changing themselves or
at least changing people's perception of
themselves manipulating the attitudes
and the responses of others to them and
in that respect I suppose that this
encourages this encourages kind of
[ __ ] a kind of dedication to
misrepresenting oneself in order to in
order to affect the way people perceive
you or the way people respond to you I
suppose that's a rather common form of
[ __ ] that we all engage in to some
extent because we are concerned with how
people feel about us how we help people
respond to us and we want them to think
about us in the way that we would like
them to think about us and so we we try
to get away with bullshitting them thank
you you're welcome professor frankfurt
like you I've spent most of my life in
education and I like to think that I've
done work at a trimming [ __ ] through
paper grading through having students
analyze a presidential debate and
whether the questions were really
answered but I sometimes wonder on the
whole part one do you think that
teachers in encouraging classroom
discussion assigning papers to encourage
as much production of [ __ ] as we do
cutting back on [ __ ] and how can a
teacher work to be sure that there's
less [ __ ] in the world because of
their teaching rather than more I'll
tell you what I think about that I think
that there's no value at all really or
practically no value in courses in logic
or reasoning or in ethics or morals
that's not the way people learn these
things they learn these things by
example
and what teachers can do is provide
compelling examples of straight thinking
and clear thought and precision in the
use of language and in the and in the in
the formation of opinions in an earlier
version of my talk I spent some time on
a distinction that I didn't bring up
here but I'll mention it now since it
fits in with what you have raised my
experience of education is that the
universities and I've taught at Yale and
at Princeton which are two of the
premier educational institutions in the
world
I believe that universities and schools
generally have both a secular or what I
call a secular function and a sacred
function the secular function is to
train people in the use of various
skills and provide them with information
that will enable them to carry on
effectively in careers once they leave
leave the university they trained them
to be accountants or engineers or
doctors or lawyers or economists or all
these things that the society needs and
which universities are really quite
effective quite successful in in
conveying they perform their secular
function quite quite adequately I think
we get good lawyers we get good doctors
and so forth the sacred function of the
university is to instill in their
students a respect for the truth a
concern for rational thought a love of
clear thinking and of sound reasoning I
don't think that universities do a very
good job in this for one thing they
don't really understand that they have
this function they think if they give
courses in various technical subjects
and they do that effectively that that's
what they are there for and they feel
that that's a successful fulfilment of
their mission also there's not much that
the university can do at the level of of
administration it's up to the individual
faculty member to provide this example
in a compelling way of sorts of things
we are talking about the other thing is
that universities have
in in the last this is a way in which
things have changed in the last 20 years
universities have decided that they have
a social function to promote welfare to
promote justice to promote equality to
encourage people to adopt and to adhere
to certain normative standards of social
organization
I'm not against welfare or justice or
equality but there are lots of
institutions in the society that are
devoted to these things and universities
are the only institutions that our
devoted or should be devoted to the
education of students at the level that
universities occupy so I think that to
the extent that the universities
perceive themselves as concerned with
developing or forming the moral
character of their students rather than
with forming the intellectual character
of their students the the university is
misunderstanding what its true purpose
is and is failing to take seriously and
therefore failing to succeed in the in
the fulfillment of its of its sacred
mission I think that very few
universities take this seriously and I
think that we're letting ourselves down
in this respect by devoting ourselves
too much to the secular aspect of the
university's mission and to the welfare
or moral aspect of university life and
not enough to the cognitive and
intellectual aspect of students
education thank you yes yes person
standing in your opinion who were the
world's five biggest bullshitters